[Music]
in the 5th century bc during the
invasion of thermopylae 300 spartan
soldiers stoically withstood the
onslaught of some two hundred thousand
persian soldiers for days on end
today two and a half thousand years
later we can find a small country with
the same philosophy of resistance
determination and popular mobilization
and no as surprising as it may seem
we're not talking about israel
[Music]
so visualpolitik fans do you have any
idea which small country we may be
talking about three two one okay yes i
know the surprise factor is not our
forte because the answer is basically in
the title of this video but we had to at
least try to drum up some excitement so
yes you got it right in this video we're
going to talk about singapore
[Music]
and not just the singapore we all know
and love but the least known singapore
the most military intimidating and
fiercely strong almost you could say the
very sparta of the century but before we
talk about defending nations let's talk
about how keeps the sponsor of today's
video can help you defend against hair
loss
believe it or not hair loss is a problem
that affects over 60 percent of men and
while there may seem to be solutions out
there finding the right one can be
tricky but keeps is a subscription
service where you can tailor an fda
approved solution to your specific stage
of hair loss even better you don't even
have to leave the house once your
treatment plan is established your
products are sent to you with the
correct amounts for daily use they also
have online medical support because hair
loss is a medical issue and you need to
be sure that the hair loss is not a
symptom of something more serious the 12
month tech support with their doctors
also allows you to check your results
and adjust treatment as necessary but
don't just take my word for it head to
their website and check the reviews for
before and after photos of real men who
have had success with this program so if
this is a problem that is bothering you
or someone you care about and you have a
us address remember hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com forward slash visualpolitik
or click the link in the description
that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash visualpolitik
[Applause]
[Music]
singapore is a small country very small
practically tiny however despite having
fewer than 6 million inhabitants and an
area of just 280 square miles or 730
square kilometers an area roughly
equivalent to that of new york city and
half the size of others such as london
or mexico city singapore is a military
power
yes yes you heard correctly we are
talking about a first-rate military
power that by itself would be able to
stand up to almost any country in the
world because it turns out that
singapore has one of the best equipped
armed forces on the planet
specifically singapore's armed forces
have just over 70 000 full-time
professional personnel some 400 000
part-time personnel and more than 1.2
million military-trained reservists
because yes in singapore there is
compulsory military service for all men
for two years it's called ns and so the
regular armed forces whether full-time
or part-time account for eight percent
of the country's entire population at
the same time the military trained and
available population represents almost a
quarter of all inhabitants of this
city-state
and that's not all since 2015 this
country has also had a volunteer army
known as the singapore armed forces
volunteer corps which is also open to
women and which allows membership up to
the age of 45 years
[Music]
in probably no other country in the
world is the population so involved in
the armed forces and we're just getting
started as you probably already know in
modern warfare the number of available
soldiers is not the most important
element in achieving victory
[Music]
above and beyond the number of troops is
the available technology and military
equipment singapore being one of the
world's wealthiest countries has not
skimped on this over the past few
decades either
for example singapore has more fighter
aircraft than the air forces of
countries such as canada sweden or the
netherlands in terms of capacity they
even rank above the air forces of
countries such as spain and we're
talking about advanced equipment
acquired from the military industry of
the united states israel and europe in
fact singapore was the first country in
all of southeast asia to get its hands
on the 5th generation f-35 fighter
obviously as you can imagine the
military budget of this country is not
exactly small especially considering
that it is a city-state
[Music]
well in 2021 this city's military
spending exceeded 11.5 billion dollars
which is almost three times the military
budget of neighboring malaysia and 25
more than the military spending of
indonesia a country with 46 times the
population
to put this in perspective we're talking
about a budget similar to that of a
territory as under threat as taiwan
pretty amazing right
singapore is a very prosperous territory
with a lot of legal security it's one of
the enclaves where the capital of
millions of investors and companies from
all over the world end up and that's the
status that needs protection and with
the data in hand it seems that they are
very very clear about this
since gaining its independence in 1965
this small asian country has had three
major military strategies three major
military strategies that explain their
perception of the world and that have
shaped their relatively large and
well-equipped armed forces over the
years
[Music]
because visualpolitik viewers nothing of
what we have told you is by chance
listen up
[Music]
the poison shrimp
the first military strategy singapore's
great defense strategy came shortly
after its independence under the
celebrated lee kuan yew the historic
first prime minister who designed
today's singapore and ruled for 20 years
the fact is that after separating from
the united kingdom integrating into
malaysia and then being expelled in just
two years lee kuan yew was very clear
that in order to survive singapore had
to become a place that no one would want
to invade an idea that he expressed very
clearly in 1966 in one of his best known
quotations
in a world where the big fish eats small
fish and the small fish eat shrimp
singapore must become a poisonous shrimp
if you eat them you'll get digestive
upsets lee kuan yew when lee kuan yew
uttered these words singapore situation
was radically different from its current
status at that time singapore was a poor
country with hardly any allies
surrounded by somewhat hostile
neighbours and having to survive in a
world torn in two singapore had to be
able to defend itself the goal was that
invading this enclave would become such
a costly operation in terms of money
lives and military resources that no
country would be tempted to do so
singapore's defense had to be able to
inflict as much damage as possible on
the enemy even if it did succeed in
overrunning the city if that happened
singapore would become the poisoned
shrimp
this strategy by the way is very similar
to the one that many analysts advocate
taiwan should adopt to defend itself
against china now the question is how to
achieve all this in practice how does a
country become a poisoned shrimp well
basically in three ways by arming
themselves to the teeth preparing for
combat and making powerful friends
the fact is that when singapore became
independent and began to go its own way
the city-state barely had two infantry
battalions one old cannon and no fighter
planes an army had to be built
practically from scratch to achieve this
lee kuan yew gave his minister for the
interior and defense gokeng sui a secret
order singapore needed to strengthen
ties with israel egypt and india
and guess what of the three countries
the most effusive response came
precisely from israel a country
desperate for friends abroad so not only
was israel one of the first states to
recognize singapore but in october 1965
barely two months after proclaiming full
independence the hebrew army was already
at work helping to design the armed
forces of this new country
of course it was not that simple the
collaboration between these two
countries had to be as discreet as
possible so discreet that no one would
know about it why well think for a
moment about the two countries
surrounding the city-state malaysia and
indonesia two large muslim countries
that at the time like virtually all
muslim countries had israel in their
sights so if singapore did not want to
be seen as a hostile element and run the
risk of justifying an invasion it had to
be inventive take a look at this
the first military advisers sent from
israel to singapore were called mexicans
in order to be discreet and take note
because in order to make it credible
israel selected members of its armed
forces for the operation whose features
would allow them to pass as mexicans so
no blonde or extremely white-skinned
soldiers and officers this particular
anecdote is told by lee kuan yew himself
in his memoirs published in 1998
[Music]
[Applause]
the fact is that out of his
collaboration came the so-called brown
book a master plan captained by the then
israel idf deputy director of operations
i want you to remember several things
one we are not going to turn singapore
into an israeli colony your task is to
teach them the military profession to
put them on their legs so that they can
run their own army second you're not
going there in order to command them but
to advise them and third you are not
arms merchants when you recommend items
to procure use the purest professional
military judgement yitzhak rabin former
chief of the general staff and prime
minister of israel
and so in just three months the israelis
created an entire military strategy and
doctrine whose central axis was to build
a citizen army of conscripts to be
trained and led by a small highly
professional and well-equipped regular
force does this structure remind you of
anything exactly it is exactly the same
model that is still in force today
[Music]
the fact is that to achieve this goal
and to get the country to have 12
battalions ready to defend the city in
less than a decade was why compulsory
military service was established
the idea basically was to ensure that
the entire nation could be mobilized if
necessary and that this enormous
capacity would be the great bastion of
the city's defense but of course as the
country became richer and the armed
forces became better equipped and better
trained it became clear that the
military strategy needed to be updated
well that moment came in the 1980s from
that moment on singapore's military
vision helped it evolve into a major
military power listen up
porcupines and dolphins singapore is
here
a decade and a half that was all the
time it took singapore to go from being
an impoverished fishing colony without
an army to being in a position to act
militarily beyond its own territorial
limits and this was precisely the basis
for singapore's second military strategy
known as the porcupine strategy which
began to be implemented in the early
1980s and brought about a huge change
singapore no longer had the need to
assume to accept that it could end up as
being invaded even if at a high cost
which was basically what the idea of
being the poisoned shrimp was all about
they now had sufficient training and
equipment to convert their passive
defense model into a much more active
one this doctrine was in force until the
arrival of the new century and was the
necessary step to finish building a
modern army
and so following the porcupine doctrine
singapore not only became an important
customer of the us israeli and european
military industries which in itself gave
it enormous influence but it also
developed its own local military
equipment industry an industry that has
allowed singapore to become one of the
30 largest arms exporters by volume
worldwide among its most successful
equipment we can highlight the sar-21
assault rifle the bronco military
all-terrain vehicle and the terrex
armored transport vehicle as well as a
host of drones and howitzers of all
kinds
but that's not the end of it singapore
is currently applying its third major
strategy known as the dolphin doctrine
shrimp porcupine and dolphin this is
just like a nature documentary but why
the dolphin well you see the dolphin is
a tremendously agile animal that is able
to use this agility to even attack
sharks despite not being as strong as
them and that is precisely the idea
under this doctrine singapore is
building an impressive air force very
strong and very agile capable of
anticipating any threat in other words
to achieve total air superiority in the
region to achieve this enormous power of
response and anticipation the current
prime minister li sien lung has launched
an ambitious plan to adapt the entire
military structure to this new mission
among the key aspects of the new
strategy is the replacement of the aging
f-16 fleet with fifth generation f-35bs
as well as the renewal and expansion of
its navy fleet which currently operates
six multi-mission frigates based on the
french lafayette class it also
highlights the acquisition of key
weapons such as german second generation
leopard tanks indigenous hunter combat
vehicles in service since 2019 and the
u.s lockheed martin m142 highmars
missile launcher of which singapore
already has two dozen units
this is how singapore first became a
militarized city and then a fortress and
now a military player capable of
applying la matim that the best defense
can be a good offense
[Music]
but wait a minute because not everything
rests on their arsenal singapore has
been enhancing military synergies with
its allies for many years especially
through military training singaporean
soldiers currently training countries as
disparate as the united states australia
thailand taiwan and south africa and
frequently participate in large-scale
defensive military exercises in addition
singapore has also sealed important
defense agreements with uncle sam
agreements that include access to
singaporean military bases for u.s
soldiers
singapore renews military base is packed
with u.s amid deepening defense ties
with china washington renews pact
granting u.s forces access to lions
cities bases until 2035 underlining the
city-state's importance to america's
asia strategy
navies of 21 countries kick off u.s lead
drills in southeast asia seacat
exercises underway in singapore and
virtually as beijing and moscow also
hold drills in china's ningxia of course
all this does not mean that singapore is
a belligerent actor not at all it is one
thing to get along well with the united
states and quite another to get along
badly with china and here singapore has
shall we say a certain advantage 69 of
the chinese have a positive image of the
city-state whose model deng xiaoping
himself took as an example for
implementing the reforms that have built
the china of today
singapore is something like a
combination of sparta's military
vocation and switzerland's historical
neutrality this visual politic community
is a great financial marketplace a haven
for capital and business from all over
the world for this both strength and
neutrality play a key role be that as it
may this is the less familiar face of
singapore its role as a military power
despite having fewer than 6 million
inhabitants and less than half the area
of the city of london now if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like and subscribe to visualpolitik if
you haven't done so already thank you
very much for being here and all the
best i'll see you next time
[Music]
you